I've got my master's degree in
everything Pablo Escobar and everything
whitey bulger I bought Lilly and I've
read through two books now on Pablo
Escobar I got this new whitey bulger
when I'm attacking now I've got the
who's a bigger [ __ ] Oh Nikki crashed
planes now hold on hold this Lila make
very [ __ ] clear and narcos does a
good job but I'm rewashing narco season
one and two with Pablo Escobar I think
it's the greatest TV of all time here's
my issue with this is they make you fall
in love with Pablo Escobar and how he's
like given Robin Hood in the poor you
got to understand something in the 80s
and the early 90s when Pablo Escobar was
in the midst of his [ __ ] you're talking
about a straight-up terrorist a
terrorist serial killer oh oh why
because he killed and this is just cops
four hundred cops a year every year he
was in business 400 cops a [ __ ] year
do chase and he's also when you talk
about money-wise you're talking about a
guy worse when when when you know he was
killed or most people including his
friends and family said he actually shot
himself he was a shot he shot himself
when he's about to get caught that's the
majority of people said he shot himself
but you're talking about a guy who was
at the time we're 30 and this is in 1992
thirty billion dollars thirty million
dollars make 640 million dollars a week
good [ __ ] god it's not what else is
crazies like narcos I was reading his
his son who's you know he was kind of
going against narcos he goes when you
watch narcos and you see like when
Pablo's on the run with his family and
they show him these cool houses and
there's pools and his helicopters he
goes that's the one thing they're so off
on that because we were not in nice
places we're in the [ __ ] in these
shanties and we were scared for our
lives it was scary and he goes everyone
makes seem like my dad was this loving
father and all this stuff he goes my dad
didn't trust anybody when we would go
from place to place he'd blindfold me
and my little sister and my wife because
he thought we were gonna snitch on his
mother yeah yeah Wow
just got a real piece of pee
piece of [ __ ] yeah he would cheat at
monopoly and cheated everything he was
just a bad guy well you know when when
they when they caught him and they want
to extradite him to America he his way
of having the government switched the
rules is by taking people hostages who
were government the children of the
cover of the elite oh and then killing
them and then killed him and then if you
didn't like that he'd blow up schools
shopping centers she's a great guy and
they blew up a [ __ ] airliner
I literally blew up an airliner full of
people and do you know how he did got
the bomb on the plane well he gave you a
17 year-old who thought he was recording
two gentlemen speaking he conned this 17
year old who just had a new baby girl he
killed there and then killed his wife
yeah yep kill the lights
yep and then one to kill the baby too so
good guy he's a very very nice guy I
mean don't get me wrong whitey Bulger's
you know he never killed anybody
who wasn't in the business you know
that's the way the the Irish mob worked
but you know [ __ ] PAH bless my time
on real [ __ ] this is a sociopath a
true socialist you a straight-up
terrorist yeah well he said he said I'm
gonna I'm gonna get them to change laws
in Colombia the extradition laws and if
they don't do it I'm gonna I'm gonna
just create so much havoc and bomb the
city centers until they do my bidding
hey guys I really he hired a guy who's
really good at these these bombs these
homemade bombs has blown up buildings
and in public places and farmers markets
and you don't about people you know now
they idolize them and there's Pablo
Escobar's painting this dude you're
talking about a guy who literally that
the entire nation was terrified people
would stay there houses do didn't you
send me a thing about Mexico this year
being the bloodiest hold up dude we're
talking about Corona we're talking about
public art right now Mexico
June was their bloodiest month ever
because they're cartel Wars going on
there check this out 114 people died in
under 24 hours due to shoes from the
cartel Jesus Christ can't there aren't
cameras where they can see this stuff
and track this stuff the way the United
States do we know why though cuz they
had a new president came in two years
ago and it's gotten worse since he was
there what happened did he take their
hands off approach yeah there well what
they're saying a lot of it is because
it's so ingrained it's so it's not only
is it in obviously the cartels and it's
a part of their culture I'll hate to say
it but it's also ingrained in their
politics one doesn't play without the
other
yeah it's it's systemic it goes all the
way to the federal level oh dude it's so
bad Jalisco cartel and all those guys
had yeah they're not working alone here
they've got people in the federal
military and police fled everybody's on
the take like my friend said he goes you
know when you talk about cartel what
you're really saying is that it's like
you got a guy whose hearings like well
my cousin works for that guy everybody's
involved in one way or another well
enough but also like in until you know
El Chapo when he got caught but one of
the only reasons El Chapo got cops
because Americans and until until you
get the Americans and that's why all
these cartel guys whatever city they're
in Colombia Mexico Russia if Americans
get called and you bring in our Special
Forces
one thing about Americans we do not
that's why all the more terrified of
America is not only gonna get you yeah
that's gonna be bad but get you on that
when that Mexico you know we took out
that Jalisco or whatever the hell they
call cartel the Americans helped out
with that and then now you know without
Chapo's sons trying to fight for power
and it's it's great it's not it's not
safe no no it's like a war going on
[ __ ] crazy man talk about stress field
stress oh my god I can't imagine so
still my girl can you imagine Pablo
Escobar just or this family on the run
but here's what's interesting is his
wife
you know after Pablo was killed every
cartel in Colombia wanted to kill her
and her kids you know just to prove a
point so they had to go into hiding and
so I'm like god that poor lady bla bla
bla Panta [ __ ] five years ago
her son get arrested on drug trafficking
Wow
yeah man they met back in business yeah
they are arrested but they couldn't they
didn't have enough evidence so they held
him for 15 months and let him go back in
the old family business and then the guy
I think that I think that people are
gonna want to get high your your biggest
market is just here north yeah the only
way the Latin American gets out of this
is by legalizing drugs yes it's the only
[ __ ] way
you mean no otherwise they they keep
paying and I'm saying I'm saying Latin
America keeps paying for our drug habit
with their blood and tears and I and if
I'm Latin America if I'm Mexico if I'm
any of those countries I [ __ ]
legalize it I go
you guys keep doing when the drugs
you're buying all the drugs so let's
legalize it we'll just [ __ ] zone it
will tax it will organize it you know
people you guys can make your money with
the big business and yeah and then I've
had the federales say look you know
everybody gets to take including us if
there's any violence though and you
start killing people you're gonna have a
problem we're just gonna focus on that
and otherwise otherwise let's shown it
let's cut it up and then it's all free
and then if you're American come on down
I mean that's what I do
yeah you look the real issue would be
you need america north north america
america to legalize drugs because then
there's no incentive to do all this
crazy [ __ ] and territory and sneak it in
and smuggle it in now you cut them out
from the legs by doing that you know
that's all you can do
well cuz whatever we're doing is not
working here's the other thing in those
cities where 140 people died in 24 hours
not only do they have to worry about
code which is hitting over there now so
you got cartel Kovan you know they they
have they have lock downs after dark
because of the cartel shootings they're
so bad it's the stay inside their house
Jesus everyone's yeah no you know we cry
about being quarantined here in the
states because the covent and being with
our loved ones but trust me could be a
lot worse yeah you can't even earn a
living yeah you start a business good
luck and they come in and go we'll take
this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]